was it an easier thing to step on that
stage the first time you did it with
Queen knowing that nobody can be
compared to Freddie Mercury the first
time the first couple of months actually
were terrifying careful yeah because I
thought there's no it's no way I should
be doing this right um you know and I
had the confidence of the band and they
were really lovely about it and they
were like not really you're great we
love it do what you want but in my head
I kept going now I don't know and you
know the audience was the final judge
and and the first audience we had was
very supportive
yeah each audience afterwards was
supportive so slowly yeah little by
little I was like okay right okay I can
do this kind of yeah but there's no
comparing Manfredi no but that does make
it a little bit easier for you though
knowing that nobody can be compared yeah
and it you're not trying right away it
was like how do I make sure that this is
not yes an imitation yeah and how did
you do that I'm asking a lot of
questions again checking in with the
guys and sort of focusing more on the
song itself as opposed to the recording
of it okay if that makes manager yeah
you know the intention of the lyrics the
the mood of the song if I kept those
things sort of in the in the forefront
of my mind yeah as opposed to having
Freddy do it yeah I usually would find
my way there but being on that stage
knowing the kind of kid that you were
you know when you were growing up you
are you flashy
gay cool indeed never big never running
away then we all know certain degree we
all try right I don't think I was ever
cool as a kid I think maybe now I may be
some you're cool we're pretty cool but
when you look out into the world the
people that you could identify fully
with the list was not very long no but
no you had to have been pretty close to
the top of that list yeah especially as
I got actually a little older when I
really really fell in love with Queen I
you know I was a little late to the game
sure I was in my my early 20s when I
really discovered their full power
majesty right and I was like this guy's
the coolest guy I've ever seen he's run
around on stage
and whatever you want he's wearing
whatever he wants I mean he was so free
and and didn't care and I just that's
rock star - yeah and and so he's
definitely you know top three rock stars
of all time in my mind do those songs
those lyrics and that stage did it
change you I think that that working
with the band has taught me a lot yeah I
think that that I've learned a lot about
song crafts and about you know how a
song connect with the mask crowd sure I
think Brian and Roger individually are
there like wealth of information and
experience and and artistry and such as
being around them through osmosis sure
like I think you know I've learned a lot
of expanded my mind to family now yeah
yeah great and that your hair how long
have been read for oh it's been since
the very start of the chewer and i love
how it looks on stage but every time I
get in front of a mirror in person I'm
like oh come on are fine so red that's
about age but it I imagine that when you
shower
it looks like psycho it look amazing
psycho shower looks like some Winston's
down yeah and every hotel I go to the
pillowcase and the towels are bright
pain I'm sorry all the mess I was out
there send me the bleach pill but again
you're on the right you're on the right
stage for that the difference between
when you do a solo show where it is
clearly an Adam Lambert audience to then
flipping and going to the classic rock
audience
do you like the different crowds I do
and I see a lot of crossover do you yes
really cool I see a lot of my fans that
I've seen on my solo tours and and well
in the front row there's a lot of these
states yeah um you know again what I was
saying about the guys I feel like the
common ground is the heart if a song is
affecting people and speaking to the
heart genre is kind of like sharing
difference and what's so great about
Queen is that we have three generations
almost every audience you have kids and
their parents and their parents so it's
a testament to their music that it
reaches everybody and your new single
yes can we say that we love to f to ask
you as how are you Aang
- fu X right I don't know there's no
like mandate on how we're supposed to
say right it's definitely you know
sounds like yeah ducks but where did was
the best song come from I actually have
some really good writer friends in LA
and when I got back from Australia last
year after judging X Factor which was so
much fun I had the blog I was like ah
going to make some music
and so I started just calling friends
seeing what they were up to and two of
my friends Sarah Hudson and frost
are both artists as well and they had
this idea to be extorted and they're
like coming this video listen to this
thing so I listened to it and I fell in
love with it and then we further
developed it together and you know it's
such a great song to just empower people
and just sort of give them the
permission to not be so concerned with
outside judgment but with a big smile on
their face it's not too serious which is
very difficult now because everybody is
so concerned about the amount of likes
and how much of your cell world removed
by its you yeah it's the society we're
living in I mean even in the ten years
since I've been on the scene you've seen
these trends shift and change and social
media is a monster it's a beautiful
thing - it can connect you with lots of
people in your fans but it has an ugly
side so being able to kind of remind
people like you know it's okay to kind
of say I don't care yeah yeah no no
four-string feels really good to deal
with that you know when you are on the
road I don't know what your social life
is like I don't know do you can you have
time for social life when you're on it -
I love you little one are you happy yeah
I'm happy I mean I being on stage with a
two hour Queen set yeah a lot of energy
yeah
so you know I try to save as much my
energy as I can for the show right as
needed and the older I get you know the
less of that spare energy I have so you
know I rest on the days off and stuff
but you have a couple days off yeah I'll
go
oh yeah mingle nice yeah are you
mingling I've always been glad are you
mingling mingle yeah yeah nice it's
singling and mingling on the road a
little bit easier than if you were
attached and touring you don't have to
deal I you know I've only been attached
while touring for a short period of time
so I don't really know much different no
I'm sort of right always singling and
mingling do you do you mingle
differently when you're doing an Adam
Lambert show compared to when you're
doing a queen and Adam Lambert show well
I don't get the private jet when I'm
doing VV Adam Lambert show my budget
code a little bit less so I have to take
a little longer to get places you're
right but yeah no I mean the cool thing
about being on tour solo is that I have
band and dancers that I've hired sure
that I've hand-picked and with this I'm
with royalty so I think we just eat it
more expensive restaurants when I'm
recruiting